it's friday july twenty ninth I'm Mary
this is Simone and it's k9 Friday here
but it's also time for gamespot's top
five news stories of the week first up
Sony financials revealed that
PlayStation accounts for seventy-eight
percent of their profits Wow Sony
Corporation has detailed its financial
results for the three month period
spanning April to June the game and
network sciences division under which
PlayStation operates was revealed to be
one of its strongest having reported
increases in sales and profits the
division cited sales at 3.2 billion
which is a fourteen percent improvement
over the same period last year operating
income was 427 million which is a
hundred and twenty-six percent increase
over last year according to Sony its
rise in sales was due to a significant
increase in ps4 software sales including
sales through the PlayStation Network
ps4 hardware cost reduction also
contributed to the improvement sales of
the ps4 were listed as 3.5 million units
this brings the total global sales of
the ps4 to around forty 3.5 million
units great job units next up more
financials Metal Gear franchise sales
top 49 million and Konami they're
reaping the benefits Kony has released
its earning report for its first fiscal
quarter revenue for the quarter was 49
point four billion yen which is about
481 million just so you know now that's
down three point five percent from what
the company generated during the same
period last year but overall Konami can
thank its health and fitness category
and to a larger extent it's digital
entertainment segment which covers
console and mobile games for turning
that profit konami has little to share
regarding upcoming projects including
what that recent metal gear solid 5
definitive x listing on amazon would be
if anything it did reveal that Metal
Gear franchise has now sold 49.2 million
units and now a Pokemon to give you all
of your weekly pokemon news first up the
gym leaders were revealed behold their
glorious faces team valor is led by
candela team mystic has blanch and team
instinct has this guy Sparky we also
learned what happens when you hit the
level cap upon hitting level 40 you get
40 ultra balls 40 max potions or
max revives 40 raspberries for incense
for incubators and for lore modules you
also get four lucky eggs now the lucky
eggs are interesting because they double
your XP received for half hour why would
you get them if you're level 40 so it
kind of hints that they're going to
raise that level cap eventually next up
for all the rumors that came along with
the Nintendo and ex this week it's
apparently portable has detachable
controllers and cartridges Nintendo's
Nick's gaming platform codenamed NX will
be portable supposedly according to
Eurogamer a number of sources have
confirmed the NX will be a powerful
handheld device will also have
controller modules that can be attached
to both sides of the screen the system
can be connected to a docking station to
use on a big screen this base unit
effectively connects what's described by
Eurogamer as the brain of the NX housed
within the portable device to a TV it
goes on to state that the NX will use
cartridges as its physical media of
choice Nintendo has a long history of
liking cartridges for its portable
gaming devices it's unclear what
capacity these cards will be available
in modern games on ps4 and Xbox one can
store 250 gigs of data the NX will
reportedly run on a proprietary
operating system designed by Nintendo
not Android as was suggested by previous
reports again these are just rumors
right now we'll have to wait for
official word from Nintendo before we
consider this legit every time we get
something cool some scuzz bud has to
ruin it for the rest of us our top story
of the week somebody got to play no
man's sky early and they uploaded a
bunch of footage we're not going to be
showing any of that footage but we are
going to talk about what a jerk that guy
is one fan got his hands on no man's sky
early and he already posted videos of it
online he purchased the ps4 copy of the
game for a really large sum according to
his post on reddit he spent twelve
hundred and fifty dollars for a chance
to play it early he also began
publishing videos of the game on
dailymotion
and he says he's gonna keep doing it
because he's a big jerk obviously Sony
and the developer hello games don't like
that they've started to remove them from
dailymotion but they're popping up
around the internet so be careful hello
games developers Sean maria's asked fans
on Twitter not to watch the videos
saying we've spent years filling no
man's sky with surprises you've spent
years waiting don't spoil it for
yourself and I agree don't look them up
enjoy it organically when this game
comes out August ninth so those are the
top five news stories of the week and
that's it for me his gains spot news
toast you'll have Jess again on Monday
have a great weekend guys